[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent renforcer la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires ces dernières années
les comportements sectees ont évolué il
ne concerne pas seulement les croyances
religieuse il se retrouve aussi dans des
secteurs comme la santé le bien-être
l'alimentation le développement
personnel le coaching et la formation
les débats au moment de la crise
sanitaire et l'utilisation des réseaux
sociaux font également partie des
facteurs de mutation du phénomène
sectaire face à cela le projet de loi
visant à renforcer la lutte contre les
dérives sectaires a pour objectif de
faciliter et de renforcer les poursuites
pénales à l'encontre de leurs auteurs
parallèlement il il permettra de
renforcer l'accompagnement des victimes
et de protéger des risques des dérives
sectaires dans le domaine de la santé
outre un durcissement des sanction le
texte prévoit par exemple la possibilité
pour davantage d'associations de se
constituer parti civil dans le cas d'un
procès et une meilleure information des
ordres
professionnels mardi 19 décembre 2023 le
Sénat a adopté le projet de loi après
l'avoir substantiellement modifié le
Sénat est ainsi revenu sur la création
de deux nouveaux délits qui reposait sur
des dispositifs juridiquement fragiles
le premier est le délit de placement ou
de maintien en état de suggestion
psychologique ou physique le second est
le déli de provocation à l'abandon ou
l'abstention de soins à l'initiative du
Sénat la mission interministérielle de
vigilance et de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires la Mivilude se voit dotter
d'un statut législatif afin de la
conforter dans ses missions les
sénateurs ont également renforcé la
répression des infractions en lien avec
les dériv sectaire dès lors qu'elles
sont commises en ligne abus de faiblesse
exercice illégal de la médecine et de la
pharmacie et pratique commercial
trompeuse afin de protéger de manière
plus efficace les mineurs des dérives
sectaires le Sénat a également allongé
les délais de prescription applica et
renforcer la répression de l'isolement
social volontaire des enfants ainsi
complété par des mesures plus
opérationnelles le projet de loi
permettra de lutter plus efficacement
contre le fléau sectaire le texte est
désormais transmis à l'Assembleé
nationale pour en savoir plus consultez
le site Internet du
[Musique]
Sénat